bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct c'est l'heure du
journal de la rédaction voici et les
titres de ce 3 juin 2014 pas de
changement pour l'île de france ça n'est
pas une surprise
notre région ne rentre pas dans le cadre
de la réforme territoriale en revanche
les annonces de françois hollande ce
matin porte aussi sur les départements
et les intercommunalités et nous verrons
ce qui va changer dans les yvelines
réaction à suivre trouver un préservatif
un centre de dépistage ou tout
simplement obtenir des conseils
pratiques
hf prévention lancent tube une
application pour smartphone
invité du journal jérôme andré président
de l'association yvelinoise vers de
farine grillon un menu de cours mais
proposé par une pépinière de la
queue-lez-yvelines préparez vos papilles
ce sera à la fin de cette édition
avant de s'attarder sur les grands
changements à attendre dans les
prochaines années sur l'avenir
territoriale de la france n'oubliez pas
ce soir que la rédaction reviendra sur
les rythmes scolaires est débat à suivre
dès 18h30 19h30 et 23 heures en présence
d'élus d'enseignants alors que c'est
justement ce mardi soir qu'une nouvelle
manifestation est prévue à maurepas
cette fois ci le conseil municipal va
délibérer sur la mise en place de la
réforme
le maire guy goerig arrestier appel à
venir grossir le rang des opposants
devant l'hôtel de ville nous en
reparlerons demain et grégory gare et
astier maire ump de meaux repas sera
l'invité du 7-8 l'actu jeudi une autre
réforme nous intéresse à présent celle
dévoilée par françois hollande ce matin
concernant l'organisation du territoire
14 régions au lieu de 22 actuellement
dans un souci d'économie d'efficacité et
l'île de france n'est pas directement
concerné ses frontières ne vont pas
changer seulement parmi les annonces du
président figurent aussi les
intercommunalités plus peuplé est la
disparition aussi des départements
réaction explications avec olivier
maniscalco patrick jacques de dixmude 14
régions au lieu de 22 dans les tuyaux
depuis quelques mois la réforme
territoriale a enfin livré son verdict
via une tribune de françois hollande
publié ce mardi dans la presse
quotidienne régionale
si six régions resteront telles qu'elles
comme l'ile-de-france où la bretagne
d'autres vont fusionner midi-pyrénées et
languedoc-roussillon alsace et lorraine
ou encore le trio centre poitou
charentes et limousin
le but de cette réforme transforme
l' architecture territoriale et faire
des économies avec moins d'élus en
supprimant dès 2020 les conseils
généraux les premières réactions à cette
annonce ne se sont pas fait attendre
si du côté de jean paul huchon président
socialiste de la région ile de france
on salue une vision ambitieuse pour le
pays du côté de l'opposition les échos
sont tout autres pour valérie pécresse
présidente du groupe ump au conseil
régional d'île de france
cette réforme n'est qu'une manoeuvre
pour gagner du temps et éviter une
déroute aux élections cantonales et
régionales
initialement prévue en mars 2015 est
repoussée à l'automne 2015
pour olivier lebrun conseiller général
ump des yvelines cette réforme est loin
d'être une priorité pour les français je
pense pas que le problème des régions
des 22 régions de 14 soit devant le
problème auquel sont confrontés les
français et françaises qui demandent
actuellement c'est du boulot de
l'activité économique forcément de
l'emploi et c'est pas en changeant ça
que ça va changer les choses pour
l'instant on met devant la charrue avant
les boeufs moi je pense encore c'est un
effet d'annoncé
et puis derrière tout ça fera sa propre
site comme comme beaucoup de choses qui
sont annoncés depuis maintenant deux ans
cette nouvelle carte de france sera voté
au plus tard à l'automne 2014
en attendant elle suscitera les débats
entre ministres et sénateurs dès la fin
du mois de juin une application pour
localiser les points de vente de
préservatifs rapidement hf prévention
vient de lancer tube sur l'appstore et
sur google plaît également bonsoir je
recommanderais bons soins président de
l'association yvelinoise on rappelle
l'inca chef prévention à servir à
travers la france afin de lutter contre
le virus du sida et les infections
sexuellement transmissibles tubes pour
trouver
et un préservatif tout simplement
comment ça fonctionne déjà
alors justement c'est très simple on
télécharge l'application et
l'application donc est gratuite et
l'idée c'est vraiment donc de cibler sur
les préservatifs puisque je rappelle les
créatifs c'est quand même l'outil numéro
1 pour se protéger des ist du sida se
protéger soi-même et protéger les autres
et en plus de ça donc tu peux trouver un
préservatif s'est dotée aussi d'une
fonctionnalité supplémentaire qui est de
trouver des lieux de dépistage
parce qu'on estime effectivement que les
gens ne vont pas assez se faire dépister
et du coup il y avait un vrai intérêt à
présenter les lieux de dépistage donc
fixe les centres de dépistage anonyme et
gratuit
mais aussi les unités mobiles un peu
comme à chaque france on est pas
seulement toutes les autres structures
qui proposent de l'unité mobile que ce
soit donc des tests rapides ou non et
bien donc on peut les retrouver
directement dans l'application vous
l'avez dit l'application est gratuite
vous pouvez la télécharger dès à présent
sur tous vos téléphones portables c'est
participatif aussi on peut ajouter des
points de distribution de préservatifs
alors nous on a rentré toutes les
pharmacies de france et des dom-tom
ainsi que les supermarchés ainsi que
tous les endroits où il y à des
préservatifs
on n'est pas à l'abri que les
distributeurs alors il ya beaucoup de
distributeurs qui ont été rentrées on
n'est pas à l'abri que les distributeurs
donc de préservatifs donc dans la rue
autres ne soient pas mis c'est pour ça
qu'il ya la possibilité de pouvoir
géolocaliser donc le distributeur en
question et de le rajouter dans la base
de données ce qui permet à chaque
citoyen de pouvoir donc consulter la
nouvelle base en enrichis grâce à eux
vous l'avais dit c'était pas uniquement
un moyen de trouver des préservatifs ya
aussi les centres de dépistage est aussi
des conseils pratiques sur l'utilisation
sur elle les conséquences d'un rapport
non protégé il ya plein d'informations
très utiles forcément est à rappeler en
permanence
mais pourquoi avoir décidé de lancer sa
sous forme d'application c'est aussi
pour toucher un autre public
c'est quelque chose de sympa nous vous
savez bien on intervient donc dans les
universités les centres commerciaux les
choeurs de cité et on se rend bien
compte que les jeunes ne se ne se
protègent plus et plus largement la
population française ne se protègent
plus on a l'impression que le sida c'est
pas chez nous 1 on a l'impression aussi
que le sida c'est très bien chez les
autres et qu'on ne peut pas être tous
chez nous je rappelle quand même que
quand on passe un centre commercial ou
dans une université 1 25 % des gens qui
ont des pistes sont séropositifs donc il
ya un vrai intérêt quand on voit qu'un
tiers des jeunes ne
n'utilisent pas le préservatif et que
près de 80% de la population française
n'utilisent pas le préservatif
il ya une vraie nécessité à être dans la
notion d' aller vers nous on a toujours
voulu aller vers les gens et leur
apporter la prévention au plus proche
d'eux quoi de plus proche que de leur
apporter directement dans leur téléphone
en faisant de la vraie prévention 2.0
c'est la première fois en france qu'une
application ce comme celle ci sort c'est
une application de santé publique et du
coup elle convient à tout le monde quel
que soit l'âge
quelle que soit la sexualité quels que
soient effectivement la personne et
l'idée c'est vraiment d'être au plus
proche des gens on a beaucoup de jeunes
ou autres qui vont chat et un sur des
sites ou des applications mobiles il
convenait un moment donné de leur
proposer une vraie application de santé
publique directement donc sur le
téléphone et vous l'avez lancé
officiellement cette application ce
matin à paris avec une conférence de
presse avec une marraine de choix vous
allez reconnaître avec ce reportage et
les médecins elle intervient aussi dans
le journal de la santé sur france 5 le
reportage de yolaine thorez et de
patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est une première en france hr
prévention en collaboration avec le
laboratoire msd lui lance la première
application smartphone de
géolocalisation de préservatifs le
principe est simple une fois que vous
avez téléchargé gratuitement
l'application elle vous géolocalise et
vous trouve un point de vente de
préservatifs ou le lieu de dépistage le
plus proche de chez vous un service 2.0
totalement anonyme
l'idée vraiment c'est de rendre service
aux gens c'est d'être une application
santé publique
une application pour chacun c'est pas du
tout de collecter des informations
aucune information n'est collecter c'est
vraiment un souhait de notre part et les
gens donc pourront directement aller
trouvez donc des pratiques qu'ils soient
gratuits ou payants
qu'ils soient en lieu fixe c'est à dire
des pharmacies des tabacs presse ou
centres commerciaux ou encore des
distributeurs dans la rue quelques
conseils pratiques pour bien utiliser le
préservatif sont également proposés
d'après marina carrère d'encausse
marraine de l'opération
ce nouveau service est indispensable
pour les jeunes mais pas seulement pour
eux je pense qu'ils peuvent aussi être
utiles pour pour des populations
quarantenaire cinquantenaire qui utilise
beaucoup maintenant aujourd'hui le
smartphone
qui eux ne sont pas du tout forcément
habitués aux préservatifs qui n'ont pas
grandi avec avec l'épidémie de sida et
qui parfois des mares des nouvelles des
nouvelles vis des nouvelles rencontres
et qui ont besoin d'apprendre à se
protéger
et ça il le trouve pas forcément ils
n'ont pas été habitués à ça on les a pas
élevé avec ça moi j'ai élevé mes enfants
avec ça on les a pas élevé avec sa donc
voilà il trouve la formation souhaitait
plus facilement avec ce genre de démo de
moyens un moyen moderne qui touchent
donc tout type de public
d'autant plus que la journaliste parle
aujourd'hui d'une véritable baisse de la
vigilance à l'égard du sida un
relâchement qui s'explique notamment par
le fait que le combat contre le virus
dure depuis 30 ans déjà
tout est allé très vite au début entre
le moment où les premiers cas sont
apparus le moment où on a découvert le
virus on a mis en place un test de
dépistage c'est allé très vite et donc
très vite en est il arrivé des
trithérapies et on a très vite on s'est
dit bon voilà ça y est c'est terminé
et depuis on oublia pas de vaccin qui
n'a pas de moyens il n'y a pas de
solution aujourd'hui qui permet d'éviter
ce virus à part des comportements
protéger 6000 à 7000 cas de
contamination sont encore détectés
chaque année d'après le président
d'hachette prévention lorsqu'on regarde
les chiffres sur les régions île de
france et nord pas de calais on pourrait
même parler de catastrophe sanitaire sur
les lieux de rencontres extérieures on
est à plus de 5% rendez vous compte plus
de 5 % de personnes nouvellement
séropositifs on peut plus parler de cris
d' allah enfin un moment donné ça
devient compliqué c'est pour ça qu'on
prend les choses à bras le corps et
consorts une application qui est une
application citoyenne tous les lieux
proposés par l'application permet
également de trouver des préservatifs
féminins sauf pour les distributeurs
l'application est disponible en
téléchargement gratuit sur les store et
sur le site www.troupefantasia.com
jérôme andré le rapprochement avec un
marina s'est fait de quelle manière très
simple très spontanément marina carrère
d'encausse eux refusent en général les
parrainages et en l'occurrence
l'histoire fait que l a vraiment
souhaité être marraine donc d'achève
prévention et plus particulièrement de
l'application youtube parce que pour
elle c'était une évidence de par son
parcours que les gens pourront découvrir
sur facebook notamment
on a créé une page spécialement pour le
tube et c'est vrai que pour le coup on
se rend bien compte que c'était une
évidence qu'elle soit la marraine
d'hachette prévention d'autant que
le journal de la santé effectivement
fait aussi beaucoup d'audience
et comme elle le dit très clairement il
faut aussi que les gens puissent avoir
donc les préservatifs proche donc de et
en l'occurrence dans une application c
c'est quand même très important avec
cette audience justement qu'elle va vous
suscitez le journal de la santé
notamment au niveau des téléchargements
déjà comment ça se passe depuis le
lancement plusieurs milliers on a râlé
stats définitive donc de la journée
d'aujourd'hui tout simplement à minuit
mais en tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'il ya énormément de gens qui ont
téléchargé l'application déjà on a
beaucoup de retours très positifs
faut voir qu'il y aura une v2 qui est
prévue avec des nouveautés plus de fun
aussi dans l'appli est ce qu'on pourra
trouver en plus de choses participative
des bdd selphy donc avec des gens qui
font des acquis qui achètent donc des
capitaux qui utilise donc équiperont les
autres les montrer on aura effectivement
des nouveaux conseils pratiques
on parlera aussi préservatif féminin
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses qui vont
être ajoutés donc dans cette première
version il fallait les sortir une
première version surtout avant l'été ce
qu'on le rappelle l'été c'est quand même
une période qui est relativement à
risque et on peut et on peut plus se
permettre aujourd'hui d'attendre la
prévention 2.0 n'a jamais été fait c'est
important maintenant de pouvoir la
sortir et on remercie d'ailleurs aussi
le laboratoire msd qui du coup s'est
engagé dans la responsabilité sociale de
l'entreprise et qui du coup a vraiment
compris qu'il était nécessaire d'avoir
ce type d'application on disait tout à
l'heure le but et vous venez de le
redire c'est de toucher un public qui
s'éloigne de plus en plus du préservatif
ce public jeune aussi notamment puisqu'à
travers les dépistages que vous
organisez vous le constatez
régulièrement ces jeunes qui découvrent
leur séropositivité
bien évidemment ne pas oublier de mettre
le préservatif mais quels sont les
autres pistes éventuellement pour
toucher concernés à un public jeune
alors faire comprendre que cette maladie
du sida tue encore et reste dangereuse
micro trottoir c'est notre question du
jour tarde à venir vraiment dans l'est
dans les lieux où sont présents les
jeunes donc à l'école l'université et
peut-être les endroits où on peut les
trouver autre que dans un cadre scolaire
qui est déjà très encadrée c'est surtout
je pense qu'il faut déjà les inciter à
prendre
la capote quoi et surtout de le faire
donc dans les écoles c'est une chose de
longue haleine je veux dire c'est pas
d'un coup qu'on va leur dire c'est tous
les jours qu'il faut leur montrer ce qui
se passe quand on porte pas de
préservatif que les méthodes actuelles
fonctionnent pas très très bien parce
que
ils sont un petit peu non pas d un fort
mais ils ont l'impression que les
traitements actuels finalement suffisent
quoi je pense réellement que mal que les
médias devraient faire des camps plus de
campagne concernant cette maladie
mortelle
c'est pas de la pause des médias en tout
cas on a entendu parler de l'aide en
parler très très jeune le plus jeune
possible d'aller dans les écoles vous
arrivez à rentrer dans les écoles alors
nous on est plutôt donc des spécialistes
des lieux de rencontres extérieures
comme vous le savez on va vraiment là où
personne ne va et on est plutôt
maintenant orientée aussi sur les
universités les centres commerciaux
là où il ya de la consommation donc
sexuels notamment et où on trouve donc
des public large mais qui vont et au
final ciblés lors de nos dépistage donc
il ya un vrai intérêt effectivement à
aller au plus proche des populations
nous on pense que c'est important et
c'est le travail c'est de l'éducation
nationale et notamment en ile-de-france
du crips ile-de-france que dalle est
donc dans les lycées les collèges pour
effectivement faire de la prévention
nous on est plutôt dans une prévention
vraiment ciblées où on va là où
effectivement il n'y a jamais eu de
prévention et où les gens donc ont une
vraie nécessité avoir de l'appréhension
et d'ailleurs l'application est
complètement cohérente avec notre
travail puisque effectivement ça va
permettre de toucher beaucoup plus de
gens que effectivement on aurait pu
l'imaginer parce que c'est vrai que
souvent on me dit mais est-ce que
l'application c'est aussi pour les
seniors
oui dans les ehpad dans les maisons de
retraite il ya des gens qui ont de la
consommation sexuelle
alors après on va vous dire oui mais
c'est pas très grave s'ils deviennent
séropositifs en étant seniors nous on
n'est pas d'accord avec ça et on pense
effectivement que ça doit être pour tout
le monde
il ya maintenant des seniors qui ont des
smartphones eh ben on les encourage
aussi à télécharger l'application et
vous serez présent j'en profite pour le
préciser au forum santé à saint quentin
en yvelines à l'espace saint quentin
centre commercial du 11 au 14 juin
prochain
je remonterai président d'hachette
prévention à l'occasion de la sortie de
cette application vous êtes venu en
plateau mais on va également vous faire
réagir sur l'actualité avec ne serait-ce
que cette affiche
voilà qu'on voit le montrer à l'écran
cette affiche pour une publicité pour un
joaillier de luxe qui a été censuré dans
une ville du département on y voit une
femme embrasser son double le maire de
pecs a décidé de la faire retirer après
des plaintes des habitants qui se sont
dits choqués quelle est votre réaction
choquée
simplement c'est nous qui sommes
effectivement choqué je vois pas où est
le mal
en tout cas il n'y a rien de
pornographique là dedans peut-être
falloir un peu arrêtez de stigmatiser
tout ce qui ne plaît pas donc au maire
du pecq
le maire du pecq donc doit comprendre
que ces habitants qui se plaignent mais
il ya aussi une grande majorité qu'il
est supposé drama ils seront une affiche
de film aussi à l'affiché
il y avait eu aussi un précédent chez
eux effectivement pour les gars les
garçons du lac est effectivement donc il
y avait eu censure
nous on pense que tout ça c'est vraiment
du grand n'importe quoi on préférerait
effectivement que les élus s'attache à
d'autres problématiques que simplement
des affiches qui font de mal à personne
et et des affiches à censurer mon dieu
si avec ça comme problème tout va bien
2013 année du mariage pour tous mais
aussi année marquée par une forte hausse
de l'homophobie rapport annuel de
l'association sos homophobie qui a été
publié le 13 mai dernier pointe du doigt
des agressions physiques verbales en
hausse une agression tous les deux jours
en france
je re précise aussi que vous intervenez
auprès d'un public homosexuel sur des
lieux de rencontre on l'a évoqué et tout
à l'heure le mariage pour tous à
renforcer l'homophobie alors ça a été
très calme et d'ailleurs les affiches
c'est un peu ça aussi c'est à dire que
est ce que le maire du pecq aurait il ya
quelques années
censure est donc cette affiche moi je le
crois pas je pense évidemment que ça a
libéré la parole
très clairement il n'y a jamais eu
autant d'actes homophobes y compris dans
les yvelines
on a nous dû monter souvent au front
alors que effectivement on est largement
donc j'en ai pas que donc sur la
communauté gay très clairement mais
c'est vrai que pour le coup on peut pas
laisser faire des choses comme ça on
peut plus laisser dire des choses comme
ça stop à la hausse aux agressions stop
aux agressions verbales stop aux
agressions physiques c'est plus possible
d'avoir de l'homophobie en france mais
que les gens se rendent compte que le
match pour tous ces actes et donc on
n'en parle plus ça a libéré donc la
parole de certains ça veut dire que le
débat a été mal mené à l'époque l'année
dernière très malmenés durant parler
différemment mais passer par un
référendum aussi pourquoi pas comme ça
il y aurait la légitimité du trading
la réforme serait passer plus vite il y
aurait moins de choses effectivement qui
se serait donc déroulé tout bêtement
et puis en l'occurrence ça fait beaucoup
débat
sauf que effectivement il ya eu beaucoup
de mariages qui se sont passées preuve
que effectivement ça répondait à des
vraies préoccupations
on a le choix maintenant donc quand on
est homosexuel de pouvoir se marier ou
non et c'est donc un choix
laissons le choix aux gens pour une fois
c'était une loi qui ne retirait rien à
personne mais qui ajoutait donc c'est
quand même malheureux de devoir défendre
des lois qui ajoute des libertés aux
gens et de voir des gens qui manifestent
contre la liberté des autres c'est quand
même juste incroyable donc en
l'occurrence le maire du pecq avec son
affiche effectivement je pense qu'il ya
d'autres priorités opecst que ce sens
sur une affiche et je pense qu'en
l'occurrence sur l'homophobie les gens
ont d'autres préoccupations que de
continuer à être homophobe et puis je
fais juste rappeler aussi en cette
condamnation aujourd'hui pour les
agresseurs de ce couple à paris en avril
dernier au moment des manifestations
contre le mariage pour tous un couple
qui avait été violemment agressé
condamnation pour les agresseurs à 30
mois de prison voilà pour cette peine
qui peut aussi rappeler que l'agression
l'homophobie est aussi un délit merci un
délit pénal pénale tout à fait merci
jérôme andré d'affaires s'améliore en
plateau avec cette application tubes
pour trouver un préservatif à
télécharger dès maintenant sur votre
téléphone portable et puis vous serez
présent pour les dépistages notamment et
puis avec cette application a présenté
au forum santé du 11 au 14 juin à saint
quentin en yvelines à l'espace
commercial 50 ans merci à vous la fête
des voisins une manifestation qui cette
année encore a rencontré un grand succès
fin mai à trappes on a choisi de prendre
son temps et c'est seulement il ya
quelques jours et qu'une réunion ait
lieu à la maison cartier au centre
social
anne est mort
une fête des voisins après leur attrape
ou réunir 3 square centre pergaud
verlaine
c'est la deuxième édition lancée à
l'initiative d'un groupe de seize jeunes
trappistes la formule séduit comme pour
ce papa adrien venue avec sa fille c'est
plutôt sympa et puis là il ya un peu
tout le monde que mis la main à la pâte
fin mai partir on a fait des gâteaux on
a apporté fin c'est vraiment vraiment
bien parce que ça implique un peu tout
le monde
pêche à la ligne concert baby-foot des
activités plutôt fédératrice aux
commandes cet après midi drissa et inès
on est déjà des amis on voulait tous
voilà faire une fête comme ça tout rond
seront concernés en ensemble on partage
tout va se retrouver ensemble à partager
des bons moments et voilà on vient de
toute la même vie qui est rap et donc sa
peur renforcer le sentiment
d'appartenance ça c était pour si
c'était sur ce but là on a créé cette
fête de voisins car avant donc on
connaissait trappe pour ces rivalités
entre quartiers tout ça mais maintenant
c'est mieux y en a plus y en a plus de
rivalité à un grand moment de nous tous
une grande grande famille faire partie
d'une grande famille c'est aussi le
sentiment de nadia connais pas tout le
monde avec le travail c'est vrai on
rentre chez nous côté pataud des voisins
les voisines
c'est clair les jeunes des trois soirs
se sont fait aider par les animateurs de
quartier une fête des voisins qui
devrait être reconduite l'année
prochaine
les insectes bientôt dans nos assiettes
dans trente ans nous serons près de 9
milliards d'humains pour la première
fois une conférence internationale
intitulée des insectes pour nourrir
l'humain s'est tenu aux pays-bas
plus proche de nous ce week end et c'est
la pépinière de la queue-lez-yvelines
qui proposait une mise en pratique le
reportage de mathilde qu'à berne et 2
jonathan vilma
ils sont repoussant voir etc unian
grillons vers de farine déshydraté il
nous donne pourtant envie d'y goûter une
expérience gustative unique mise au
point par un chef d'entreprise
romain fessard pionnier dans les
insectes comestibles
son but faire découvrir les bestioles
consommables au plus grand nombre
on pense que sérieusement que c'est
l'alimentation de demain qu'il est temps
de faire goûter aux gens or des produits
qu'on a voulu assez attractif en
proposant une sélection d'insectes de
qualité qui sont assez jolis comme les
grillons et les airs de famille avec en
plus des aromates les grilles ont un
goût de noisette qui est très léger mais
un petit goût de noisette les vers de
farine nature naturelles ont un goût de
chips au poulet sauce barbecue
thaïlandaise ou curry l'insecte se
cuisine avec tous il se retrouve aussi
en sucre et de quoi plaire aux
consommateurs tous que petit encore ça
va aller mais tout ce qui est gros
spéciale je sais pas encore faut que ça
rentre quand même c'est vraiment trop
grand c'est comme de petites pizzas en
perd autant qu'il sera se mange très
bien
très à gauche très bon ça va changer un
peu de dkk weight et puis des chips vous
pouvez les mettre un apéritif un petit
peu bien sûr je l'aimé pour ça on va
faire un apéritif pour juste avant leur
faire goûter et puis les faire crier
bien sûr l'intérêt est avant tout
écologique les insectes consomment
beaucoup moins d'énergie d'eau et
prennent moins de place que les bovins
par exemple les petites bêtes sont elles
alors l'avenir de l'homme selon notre
spécialiste
elles ne remplaceront pas totalement la
viande mais santé effectivement bon
apéro avait en sport en football ce
mardi soir le club de trappes va
annoncer la signature du jeune nissim
rafa 15 ans par une formation évoluant
en ligue 2 le stade lavallois jusqu'à
présent inscrits en dh il va intégrer la
cellule de développement de ce club
avant on l'espère pour lui de débuter
une carrière professionnelle nous y
reviendrons dans notre édition du
mercredi du journal
et puis dans le 7-8 sport également
lundi prochain à 18h30 en direct
toujours du sport dans le cadre de la
journée de basket féminin de promotion
du basket féminin plus de 200 jeunes
joueuses se sont rassemblés à maurepas
malgré les succès récents de l'équipe de
france au niveau international les clubs
ont du mal à retrouver les demoiselles
sur les parquets anthony rech
les basketteuses yvelinoise représente à
l'heure actuelle 27 % des effectifs du
département
cela reste dans la moyenne francilienne
mais le bât blesse surtout dans les
toutes petites catégories où les
demoiselles désertent les parquets
depuis plusieurs saisons comme c'est le
cas à maurepas un club de plus de 300
licenciés
historiquement féminin depuis ses débuts
on explique ça sur le nombre de sports
qui peut y avoir la diversité sur mortal
à présent pour fidéliser sur les années
souvent les enfants et c'est une année
arrête on ne peut revenir dans deux ou
trois ans l'objectif de cette journée
montrer qu'il y à bien des féminines qui
joue au basket car la discipline encore
une réputation de sport deux garçons
malgré les bonnes performances récentes
de l'équipe de france pour attirer les
filles sur les parquets dès la saison
prochaine
le comité départemental va créer des
formules spécifiques
on va tester auprès d'un certain nombre
de clubs pilotes
le fait d'avoir une offre purement
féminine à partir la saison prochaine
c'est à dire mettre des petites baby et
petites possibles et prenez des
possibles à 100% entre elle et pas noyé
au milieu des garçons à maurepas le club
va également tenter de nouer des
partenariats avec les écoles de la
commune pour recruter de nouvelles
joueuses
des initiatives qui ont pour but
d'atteindre en 2016 la barre des 3000
licenciées féminines dans le département
fort de ce journal du 3 juin je vous
retrouve demain toujours en direct dès
18h 19h pour la première diffusion et
22h30 bonne soirée